une vaccination à retardement qui a pu
démarrer grâce à la serbie ce mercredi
la bosnie herzégovine administrer ses
premières doses de vaccin au personnel
soignant et technique d'un hôpital de
sarajevo
alors même que le pays connaît une
flambée épidémique
c'est un don de 10 mille doses du vaccin
astrazeneca réalisé par belgrade qui a
permis les premières injections
l'urgence se fait de plus en plus sentir
si nous repoussons la vaccination à
l'année prochaine cela n'aura aucun
effet nous devons nous procurer une
quantité importante de vaccins dès que
possible
vacciner rapidement et grâce à des
mesures restrictives strictes nous
pouvons ralentir l'épidémie
nous ne pouvons pas empêcher la
propagation de l'infection maintenant
car nous avons quatre semaines de retard
dans le cadre du programme international
kovacs initiée par l' oms
la bosnie avait commandé plus d'un
million deux cent mille doses de vaccin
mais les premières livraisons n'ont
toujours pas été effectuée
la ministre des affaires étrangères fait
part du mécontentement de la population
la bosnie herzégovine accrue aux
mécanismes kovacs à payer pour la
vaccination
mais la première livraison ne nous est
toujours pas parvenus et nos citoyens
sont à juste titre mais content pour 3
millions huit cent mille habitants
la bosnie enregistre plus de 5000 décès
duo kobe 19,1 des chiffres les plus
élevés proportionnellement à sa
population le retard sur la vaccination
n'aide en rien le recul de l'épidémie
le bénéfice le plus important du vaccin
et que chacun d'entre nous qui est
vacciné ne mourra pas s'il vous plaît
c'est le bénéfice principal sans parler
de la prévention de la propagation du
virus
je n'ai pas d'anticorps et chaque jour
de travail pour moi un stress j'espère
que ce stress sera désormais réduits si
d'ici à quinze ou vingt jours mes
collègues sont affectés de la même façon
face à une recrudescence des cas les
autorités de sarajevo ont annoncé la
fermeture des bars restaurants et
magasins non essentiels pour le week-end
prochain
la pression sur les hôpitaux étant
critique
les médecins ont également insisté pour
que la vaccination soit étendu à
l'ensemble de la population le plus
rapidement possible